my guest tonight played the title role
in the hugely
successful karate kid films now 36 years
later
he's reprised the character of daniel
russo
on netflix's cobra kai one of the
hottest shows in the country
right now i think everyone's watching
this through uh kovid
please welcome ralph macho ralph thanks
for joining us
hey conan great to be here thanks where
first of all where are you are you on
the east coast
i am on the east coast i'm on the east
end of long island as we speak or long
island
challenge long island yeah yeah good all
right well
i'm in an abandoned theater you're in
los angeles and i look like a pervert i
look like a guy that
that broke into a closed sex house
basically
i apologize for that but what are you
going to do these are strange i expect i
expect nothing less
thank thank you nicest thing anyone said
to me in half an hour
ralph uh first of all um i want to
congratulate you on cobra kai
uh i have watched i think almost all of
them
i am loving the show uh i'm really
enjoying it
it seems like the perfect show right now
because um it's this nice dose of
nostalgia
it's really fun and the show has a great
sense of humor it's
so i'm enjoying it it's it's a great
quarantine show
what's the response you're hearing from
people well we'll take we'll take the
great quarantine i'll take the great
show no matter what but the uh it is the
i call it the comfort food you know it's
it's that big fat nostalgic embrace
and yet it's telling uh relevant stories
for today and a great young cast
and uh it's just hitting on all
cylinders and um
that's this sort of blessing i mean this
has been i call it the second
rebirth of the rebirth of the original
movie you know we came out a few years
ago on youtube premium and
now netflix it's just blown out of the
water all over the world and it's yeah
it's it's a great time for the show and
it's nice to be
um an alternative to the hell that we're
we are living with every day and i'll
tell you how you're affecting my life
which is
one of the ways you know right now in
addition to quarantine we've also have
uh so much smoke in the air here in the
west
you can't go outside i have a treadmill
in the basement
it's in a tiny room and there's a small
tv there and i will binge watch cobra
kai
and i'm on the treadmill and what
happens is when it builds up to a fight
scene
i crank the treadmill so i'm running at
like
60 miles an hour bare-chested
it's not a pretty it's not a pretty
sight i'll get a picture
because you clearly want one but i'm
running full out as
the kid is beating up the bullies in the
cafeteria and i'm like
my family comes running downstairs
because they think i've had
a major heart attack right back right
yeah
and it's and the show is uh laced with
his great
80s homage music yes
that time the training montages and all
that stuff it is
it is uh kick-ass in that way and that's
that's awesome well i'm
i'm glad to help out in your cardio and
everything else
yes it's so you know you mentioned 80s
and nostalgia i've got some pictures
here i'm sure your life has been being
confronted by these pictures
yes yeah exactly uh first of all
let's sue the guy who convinced you to
do that pose i know i know
there's so many there's many others that
that is not the one i'm actually glad
that was the one you well let's see
what's next no no no no i've got this
one
too oh well that's from a movie that's
from a movie that's your
movie with nick nolte i know i know i
know but
uh any kid who's wearing that hat to
school needs to know karate
[Laughter]
you uh you know it's funny because all
these pictures
i i you and i i think are just about the
same age
and there are the saving grace for me is
there are no photographs of me until i'm
about 30.
i was unphotographed i'm like someone
that was born in the 1850s there's no
photograph of me and then they start
around the time i'm 29 or 30.
what's it like for your kids when
they're on the internet and this pops up
and they say
dad what the thinking
and it gives them leverage great amounts
of leverage yeah
um it's uh you know i mean what are you
what are you gonna do it's kind of fun
because when my kids were uh my daughter
was like
four when she first saw the karate kid
maybe five and
um and so it was one of those things we
were we were tour i was doing a
broadway musical around the country uh
called how to succeed and i was playing
the lead in the show
and every city we would go to these
planet hollywoods which were big deals
back in the early 90s
and we grabbed lunch there with the with
uh
my kids and my daughter would see this
memorabilia up and ask these questions
like
why are people standing on one leg and
holding their arms up in the air when
they see daddy and what is that
headband why are they wearing it and
then finally it was like well
you know it's time to sit you down honey
daddy's not like all the other daddies
um and then we i showed her the film at
four years old literally
karate kid at four yeah five five years
old like it was five because we got back
when she was five
and i showed her that and in thinking
that it would i would make her proud
and not not thinking that i get my ass
kicked in every other scene
and she's watching her dad be beaten to
a possibility
running out of the room so that was uh
an epic parent fail by
by me yeah you scarred your child for
life yeah um
although i have to say my children at
any point in their lives
would love nothing more than to see
footage of being beaten
it might have changed to that when she
got through middle school but at five
she really you know i was a hero for a
moment yeah
and my son my son on the flip side found
all those teen magazine kind of pictures
when he was about
the same age and ran into
the family room to my daughter and said
look dad was huge and we missed it
so so fortunately for me right now with
cobra's ice show
uh dad may not be that huge but they're
not missing it
well uh what you guys have been like the
number one show on yeah we are huge
let's say
huge i mean let's just say that this is
uh
and and you know another thing i want to
say about the show that i i really love
is there's a sense there's a real funny
sense of humor and self-awareness about
the show
so i love there are these scenes where
johnny lawrence you know uh the bully in
the original karate kid
he's struggling and he doesn't
understand that the 80s are over
and he's touching scenes where he's like
trying to hock his
he's trying to sell his atari console
right we don't give a [ __ ] about this
anymore
um he's very good at at tapping into
it's almost in a comical way he doesn't
understand
that it hasn't been the 80s for a long
time he missed someone didn't tell him
that things have changed yeah it's
refreshing to have a character like that
who is not politically correct in any
way shape or form and represent
a lot of what a lot of many people think
but
can't or won't say so i think there's a
release with that because we're so
overprotective of everything yes
the anti-hero and you know you root for
that redemption that's the cool thing
about the show
is it really your allegiance to each
character can change episode to episode
right because it dives more into the
gray areas of who
these guys are and even the young
characters as opposed to the black and
white of what karate kid was good or
evil you know right
well what's happened interestingly
enough is that
initially karate kid and i remembered
seeing it in the theater when it came
out
uh was about you know
you are clearly the protagonist you're
the underdog you're the hero
and then it's clear who uh the bully is
johnny lawrence
what happened over time and it's kind of
a tribute to the
film is that people got into these these
discussion groups
and it sort of became part of uh uh
almost a cultural question of
real bully right because he has the
cruel sensei and you have the nice
sensei
you take his girlfriend you know
and and it it it became um those are the
intellectual discussions of our time
basically you've laid it out you've laid
it out beautifully
yeah it's it has become pop culture i
mean it's really become that there are
fan videos
theories the crane kick was illegal um
you know you say he took his girlfriend
well
you know she was uh i mean we could go
on and on
about that i defend uh i defend larusso
but it's fun
it's fun to people care i mean they've
cared for 35
36 years and now it's um it's lifted to
another level
um but ralph ralph be honest there were
times when you wake up in the middle of
the night
covered in sweat screaming the crane
kick was legal
more more often than you know
i must confess on the conan o'brien show
do you ever do that do you ever
getting a latte and someone's just
giving you a look a little a little like
it was legal
i'm doing that i'm doing it there you go
i love it well
every every day this week i'm doing that
you know it's so funny because
uh during i've not had a haircut as you
can tell
or as many people can tell during uh
during the pandemic and so for the first
time in years my hair's been getting in
my eyes
so a couple of months ago i started
wearing uh not on the air but just
around
uh when we're doing the shows and we're
taping them my assistant who's always
socially distant but i'll be talking to
her
and i'll be wearing this thing to keep
the hair out of my eyes and one day
she was like you look like somebody you
remind me of somebody and i'm like
who and then she said you look like
johnny lawrence and i realized
because i'm usually scowling at her
right so you have the bad ass kind of
i've got the badass i mean i'm not as
you know good looking as this guy but
i had that kind of you know sort of
blondish
guy with my hair up and i'd be telling
her things like you can't handle it sona
come on give me my coffee and she'd say
oh my god
you're cooking well enough alone
that's what you should have to say once
you vote i often dress up in a skeleton
costume
yeah i can only want her at night you
know one question i have
is that uh you seem to be in really good
shape you seem like you've taken care of
yourself
but and i'm speaking as someone who i
believe is roughly the same age you know
you've got to do some stunts now
and i and it probably started out with
you just the occasional i have to kick
coffee an iced coffee or a boba tea in
someone's hand
yeah but um okay there's that
but then they just keep ratching it up
how are you handling matt because you're
not a 17
18 year old kid anymore it hurts it all
it's all a lot of stretching i mean
you know even when the show was pitched
to me you know
it was in my view i'm saying to myself
well i'll throw a kick
a punch i'll you know demonstrate but
the kids will carry all the weight you
know and then once i got in and we did
season one and then season two and then
subsequently season three which is
coming out in 2021
every year there's more and more yeah
none of us are getting younger it takes
uh it takes a lot more work
and it takes uh it hurts
that's right it just hurts and the
stretching is big and the next day
you're walking kind of silly
yeah i would um if i had to just do
just even the kick that you do the first
time your your character
uh kicks uh has to do a big kick
and it's just in that car dealership
where you have to knock uh you know
a boba tea out of someone's hand if i
did that my groin would have fallen off
yes it would have literally detached
from my body
and then we would have spent maybe six
months sewing it back in
yeah it's tough to do i mean you know
billy works hard at it he's uh
you know he's i've always he's always
been more of an athlete than i i was
even from day one
but we all uh we all have our war
stories you know
it's uh we get through it man
we get through it well i owe you a huge
debt of thanks because as you know
about a year or so ago and to back it up
a little bit all of
my fans know that i've had a long
running feud
with a guy on our staff named jordan
schlansky
yep slansky is a total pain in the ass
um and uh he's a big know-it-all
and then you did me this amazing favor
i took jordan to uh to japan
and he jordan says that he knows
everything about japan
also his one of his favorite movies of
all time is karate kid
and then karate kid 2 the whole
franchise
and he started to shoot off his mouth
as i knew he would about how he
knows that karate kid two was shot in
okinawa i think
and i secretly asked you would you tape
a uh would you take a message
of you straightening jordan out
and you did that your entire fascination
with japan stems from the fact that you
saw
karate kid two yeah
and then it was filmed in where okinawa
okinawa i have a message here for you
please press play
and uh hold that out to the camera as
you watch it
hi conan it's me ralph macchio listen
i'm sorry to interrupt i just wanted to
tell that jordan guy that all the scenes
in karate kid part 2 that was supposed
to be japan were actually shot in hawaii
oh and jordan those weren't real
dinosaurs in jurassic park
i cannot tell you what that meant to me
that was so sweet he's still recovering
you appeared out of thin air his
childhood hero appeared out of thin air
and said jordan i side with conan
you're wrong it was it was perfect
i you know it's funny because you get
asked to do or i've gotten asked to do
you know these sketch things you get the
[ __ ] hey would you do this for
whoever whoever and it's usually a
one-off joke that
that this show gets a lot more mileage
out of than i do
yeah this one came to me it's like the
the perfect time with the
with a couple of suggestions each one
better than the next i
said you know what i was in my office i
said okay let me just throw this up on
the phone
and see if it works and it just it
killed man
it killed it we were playing it on the
set
of cobra kai when we were shooting it
and everybody was um
um going i could get to macchio i could
get to macchio
because that was sort of the yes
the pronunciation of my name yes jordan
was so mad
he was so mad at me in that moment he
couldn't just take the joke and go
okay pretty good you got me he
he just kept saying oh you think you're
so big because you you you're the star
of the show
well i could get to macchio i could get
you it's machio
this is great your hero how do you know
it's machio
and my single favorite line of that that
of that year probably was
your childhood hero came out of my phone
and took a [ __ ] in your mouth
because you delivered it beautifully i
laugh out loud every time and
subsequently now
and maybe it's because of the conan
o'brien show and we'll give some props
to jordan even though i know you hate to
do it
i have been to okinawa or some shooting
of uh
cobra kai season three ah which i
cannot talk too much about but i could
say
it dives into the origin of miyagido
karate
wow okay a little bit uh some secrets of
uh past history that is new to the
audience and to larusso
yeah my character and we actually went
to okinawa to shoot so
i think you guys put that in the ether
and
uh so yeah retroactively you've proven
jordan right
yes i have but but not after killing him
and squashing him and [ __ ] in his
mouth
all right we have a clip here uh from
from cobra kai and uh
i believe this is where basically
you are finding out that your old
nemesis
johnny lawrence has set up the cobra kai
uh dojo dojo in the mini mall
you realize that this he's brought it
back
you can't believe it and you go in and
there's
kind of a quasi confrontation here which
is kind of cool
i think that sets it up let's take a
look at this clip from cobra kai
is there anything else you need me to do
i'm sorry sensei i sensei
really oh my god kid i don't know what
he's told you but you shouldn't believe
a word this guy says so you're gonna end
up exactly like him
you and i this we aren't done
i'm right here man
you know what i'm really happy for you
this is uh i'm really happy for your
success
and uh i'm happy that um and again
thank you so much for destroying jordan
schlansky for me that's right
i owe you anytime you need any video
from me if you can ever find someone
who's a big fan of mine i'll do this
i'll i'll start looking start looking i
won't be that difficult
um i love i'll start looking right well
you set me up you threw me a beach truck
that over the middle of the plate i had
a swing um
thank you that was an illegal kick to me
uh the first two seasons of cobra kai
are streaming now on netflix
and uh it is a really fun show if you're
not watching it
get started because it's a joy and uh
ralph thank you so much
really good talking to you i appreciate
it man thank you so much